say I still definitely have a ways to go
uh but I'm working on it yeah I mean I'm
open with audience I'm I made a lot of
mistakes now I got really lucky and I
landed with the husband and the baby and
I had a baby late but I'm trying to like
warn women it does it doesn't always go
that way and there's a lot that can go
wrong in the Paradigm if you're
following like bury your head in the
work and you know you want a family but
you don't prioritize that until you're
30. what do you think is first of all do
the women that come to your show do you
think they believe what they're saying
I think sometimes as women we don't even
like realize what we're saying isn't
true
like you think they have that like
moment where they're like did I just and
then they wear it into me before yeah
where okay I'll say like okay the
cheating thing you know damn well that
and like I just use NBA players because
they're so like it's just easy to use
them as an example you know damn well
that a man in Tiger Woods position let's
use Tiger Woods even even my father who
is a great guy he would have a hard time
if there was a Bus full of models
waiting for him every day some guys are
nerds they kind of avoid those
situations but by even even you know and
I would say any guy any guy is gonna
have a hard time if these girls are
sitting at home trying to you know his
wife mouths off after work he's like you
know what just this one day and you know
even me like saying that and like an
intuitive level I kind of knew that but
I was like what no no my dad doesn't
cheeks we got trigger trigger so and
what is that do you think because I
think that emotion happens it is emotion
but there is so much programming that
goes on like even you know me I sat here
and you know my whole career I'm like
defending masculinity and defending men
and do believe in the traditional family
I didn't have a prince who was passed I
never went that route so I'm sitting
here thinking like oh feminism didn't
get me but then I watched an amputate
video about self-defense and I'm like
you know so it it gets you even if you
don't realize it so I'm wondering like
how many women have this like
programming and they don't really
realize it and it takes like a lot of
self-reflection really to sit back and
say wow did this really make me happy is
that good advice like why am I so mad
and that was what I had to realize with
my volleyball career I was like oh my
gosh that probably was a poor choice and
it's hard because I love like I love I
could if I could do anything in life
even before the party I'd be a
volleyball player if there was money in
women's sports why do you say it was bad
choice then because it was like I spent
that was all I did that was all I cared
about and I would say you know on the on
the plus side it avoid like a lot of bad
situations like like I avoid it because
I was just like volleyball volleyball
volleyball but you know
um it wasn't really smart to like
prioritize that when there's no future
in it you know is it hard for you with
the values that you have right now to be
in the dating world like do you think
that women who espouse how you feel
about life do you think they have a hard
time
given you know how many women are
willing to sleep around and do this and
do that is it hard
um does it feel challenging for you
I mean yeah I think if it wasn't
challenging I'd be married right yeah
out of the outcome I don't know how
picky you are one never does now you
know you might have that long list like
some of the girls here now I mean I
think I think about all they gotta be
look and I was thinking about this I was
like being tall it like makes it a lot
harder for sure dude okay I have to a
moment with the audience too
Pearl walked in now everyone knows I'm
like a small person like I'm I look like
you know the Wizard of Oz and Munchkins
that's me but I walked in I was like
what you were like you got like super
model height yeah no I'm not real I
would say if there's one thing that's
held me back in dating it is the height
I think so oh my gosh yeah now is that
because you want a guy taller it's me
it's my fault yeah no I'd actually say
I'd go down to like five ten I'd say
like an introduction then you wear the
heels though you're taller no that's
fine I don't mind definitely I'm wearing
heels but I'm just like being honest you
know and maybe maybe that's too picky I
don't know but um I would say that's
probably like if I had to pick one thing
the height that makes it a lot harder so
what I find when I when I cover these
panels yours sometimes we showcase here
is that women are so they don't realize
how picky they are you know they'll say
like oh I'm not picky I'm just looking
for a nice guy and then it's like the
list is a mile long it's like Santa
scroll it unfolds got to make a certain
amount of money you got to be this
height you gotta do you have this car
and this house and this job and so it's
just like what what is that always the
case well what's gone on that women are
so picky or is it just like a lack of
self-awareness I mean I think it's like
natural to us like we I mean if you take
our mating strategy down to the roots
it's to get the best possible mate
actually I don't mind women being picky
I just think it's like do you deserve it
right yeah well that's it 250 pounds
Rebecca you're 250 pounds what do you
mean you mean a guy that makes six
figures right you're two and then they
get to the 300 ones they're even more
picky yeah it's like what yeah I saw you
had a an exchange with somebody that
wanted I don't remember what the ring
was the cost was asking oh my God that
was a red pill moment for me that was
that was early that was early it was
before the channel took off I did it I
covered it I couldn't believe it I found
it I said she was talking like she
deserved and I'm always like you know
what do you bring to the table as a
female I say like to women you can't
just demand all this stuff and then say
well you know you I give this you know
what what does that mean you know what
are you bringing to a guy and then if
you ask them you know hey do you want to
keep a nice home they get insulted or
hey do you you know maybe you're a
little overweight do you care about you
can't say that you can't you can't ask
them to step up in any way it seems why
oh gosh well I just think like from from
a young age we've been told that we're
princesses and queens and we deserve to
be treated like that that's true you're
an average chick why do you deserve to
be treated like that
you slept with the whole football team
why on Earth would he treat you like a
queen
like and so it's like
um yeah I just think from a young age
well-meaning fathers oftentimes like
deluded our standards I haven't seen it
in the church oh my gosh were you are
you religious I'm Catholic I went to
Catholic School oh my gosh me too okay
okay I need to know if we have the same
Catholic School experience okay let's go
because I've always been in Pearl you
know I've been maybe more a blue pilled
Pearl right but I've always had opinions
and I remember thinking okay in the
Catholic did you have Chastity speakers
no oh you didn't have that capacity oh
yeah yeah okay okay this is just a pearl
experience so they they bring in you
know how there's like sex ed in public
schools yeah we didn't have sex side we
had Chastity speakers that's why when
everyone's like we need sex out and I'm
like okay I didn't do [ __ ] in high
school so I don't know what like I
didn't need sex to add to know so you're
like you need Chastity speakers yeah
yeah but I remember there was like a guy
and a girl that came in it's like
Christina or something and Jason Everett
chat can find it and they came in
it's like the girl that's been ran
through okay and her husband that was
the Virgin until he was married when
you're red pill you're like oh my God
and it's like you you know you can't
even absorb that he's just like yeah and
so she would talk about she was so broke
like it was the same message right and I
appreciate that same message but the
message in the church is like they at
the end of the day there will be a
prince waiting for you no matter what
you do no matter what you do and that's
why I was like when the guys are like
the girls are worse in the church I'm
like well this is why yeah because they
say at the end of at the end of your
whatever there'll still be a guy waiting
for you that might not be the case
Rebecca no I'm curious though because
you brought up Catholic School like what
because we're you know quite a bit apart
in terms of age but what was it like for
you to be in school like in terms of
were there a lot of girls who were
promiscuous because when I went to
school there was like there were girls
who did that but you could like identify
it was like this one over here this one
over here they had a reputation and a
bad one and all the guys like knew who
they were could we could we Define
promiscuous because that sleeps around
okay what is so then we go into like
what is sleep surround as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible